rassemblement très aisée par son début
d'après midi sur la place de la
révolution
de quoi donner des sueurs froides aux
organisateurs une semaine après une
manifestation massive 1400 personnes
pour protester contre le projet de loi
sécurité globale finalement avec les
mêmes revendications les mêmes slogans
ils étaient 700 un défilé jusqu'à la
préfecture
c'est une loi qui me fait peur puisque
on a l'impression que qu'on s'éloigne de
l'idéal démocratique tel que mes parents
l'ont vécue
syndicats partis politiques associations
une mobilisation très large contre un
projet de loi jugée liberticide
avec en toile de fond la question
sociale aggravée par la pandémie
de plus depuis le confinement six cent
mille chômeurs 300000 sdf 35 mille
emplois supprimés depuis septembre 2000
votes
on est une véritable déferlante de
faillite qui est devant nous avec des
gens qui vont basculer dans la pauvreté
le pas en arrière du gouvernement avec
la proposition de réécriture de
l'article 24 sur l'encadrement de la
presse n'a pas suffi à calmer la rue de
manifestation en manifestation la
revendication semble plutôt s'élargir
il aurait fallu une loi qui réconcilie
réellement la police avec l'ensemble de
la population n'est pas uniquement avec
des gens que - vie ont des choses à
protéger etc
je pense à tout le monde de quoi et je
trouve cette loi
y'a rien qui permette d'avoir une vraie
police et républicaine quoi on voit très
bien où ce gouvernement et si nous
amener à chaque fois vous voyez le
poisson permanence on a expliqué toutes
les revendications n'a pas l'air faire
tout de suite mais en tout cas nous ce
qu'on demande c'est ça c'est bien le
retrait de ce projet de loi est ce
l'effet de l'interview du président de
la république aux médias en ligne brut
ou la désertion du campus par les
étudiants il y avait en tout cas peu de
jeunes dans le cortège cet après midi